Speaker 1: Yet another Republican has been caught
committing voter fraud. A Republican's wife has
been arrested for casting 23 fraudulent votes for
her husband. Remember, voter fraud of this kind
is very rare. But when we find it, it's almost
always Republicans. Insider reports that Kim
Fong Taylor was arrested and accused of multiple
counts of voter fraud. Prosecutors say that she
cast 23 fraudulent votes for her husband in the.
2020 election. Her husband, Jeremy Taylor, is an
elected Republican. There's an 11 page indictment.
It is wild. It claims that Kim Phuong Taylor,
quote, visited numerous households within the
Vietnamese community in Woodbury County. She
collected absentee ballots from people who weren't
there, filled them out, cast the ballots herself,
quote, causing the casting of votes in the
names of residents who had no knowledge of
and had not consented to the casting of their
ballots. Taylor is also accused of signing
voter registration forms on behalf of residents
who were not present. That's a crime. In total,
it is 26 counts of providing false information,
three counts of fraudulent registration,
and 23 counts of fraudulent voting. Each charge
carries a maximum five year prison sentence.
Wow. The goal was to get her husband elected. I
want to remind people again and again and again,
and I will continue saying this until I don't need
to say it anymore. Voter fraud is very rare. It's
also a pretty futile strategy that is not likely
to win an election. And the potential consequences
of getting caught make it very much not worth
the risk. Up to five years potentially for each
of those counts. She's not going to get, you know,
it's 50 counts total five years. She's not going
to get 250 years. I will bet any amount of money
on that. But the risk reward is very much out of
balance. Voter fraud is a really ineffective and
inefficient way to try to win an election because
the number of fraudulent votes is almost always
too small to actually impact the outcome. And the
risk of getting caught for voter fraud is high.
Now, Republicans will say everybody's getting away
with voter fraud. All these Democrats are getting
away with it. The truth is, there is no reason to
believe that that's the case. And we've seen the
Brennan Center for Justice study. The numbers,
the penalties for being caught are severe. It is
a really bad political strategy. It's relatively
easily detected. And it would be better for these
people to spend their energy on activating voters,
help make the case that voters should vote for a
candidate because they think that that candidate
would actually do good things for them. I
know it's like a crazy thing to think about,
but that would be a much better way to spend
your time. And the last element of this is.
When people get caught. It's almost always
Republicans, even though Republicans claim
it's Democrats that do this. Now, one
could say, David, Democrats are doing it,
but they're getting away with it. Republicans are
getting caught, but way more Democrats do it and
get away with it. Well, you've got to defend
that with some data. Why is it that Democrats
are so much smarter and able to get away with
it? There is no evidence of that whatsoever.